you are inspiring so many people with a  show  you have a good karma can't believe you  said that yeah  good karma i think so  well  [Laughter]  doesn't this concern you as a buddhist  look we're sitting here  yeah in provence so wherever we just had  this fantastic meal  yeah we're moving on to the 2011 after  the 2010.  life admittedly for you has been pretty  sweet yeah  isn't that worrying to you we're sitting  in provence it's like a wine label the  next lights cannot possibly be better  than this  it's probably gonna suck enjoy every  minute of this now error  and pray pray pray that this is it  because if you're right and there is a  next life  we are my friend i may come back as a  sea cucumber  but you're coming back as like a yorkie  or you know if you're lucky  [Music]  you